how many of you guys follow kaylee
mckenney do you guys watch the press
i did yeah i do it's almost like
watching some kind of like verbal
and political mma yeah you know and
she's she's a beast
she's the best she's a freaking fighter
man so it's such a pleasure to watch her
shut them down weren't you saying they
have like
her her folder has tabs yeah so they
they thought they were gonna get another
gotcha because they took a picture of
her
her folder yeah she has like 60 tabs she
has like the economy she has the family
she has the cdc
yeah what are you going to bring up this
time yeah what are you going to bring up
she's got it yeah
she'll pull out you know someone will
ask her something like whoa when it
comes to the covet that's going um
interesting and then she like pulls some
papers out and she's like well it says
here
bring it on that's what it looks like
she's just like oh yeah come on with it
bring it i got the information you you
may
you may like seeing the media get
smacked down but they got her
sure oh they got her bailey yeah let's
talk about it they put her through the
blender
actually they're lying and taking out of
context and we have one of the best
examples of them doing it
now i will admit before we get started
poor choice of words
from kaylee mckinney and this is it this
is literally like
watching political mma yeah you're
watching you know two people are
fighting one guy you see him make a
wrong step
and the other guy goes whom and goes
right for that punch you know he sees
you're off but you're off base you're
off balance i got you yeah that's what
happened
while she's normally this you know
machine with all the facts
she unfortunately framed phrased
something
although the context was fine right the
phrasing was a weapon out of context
oh and they're using it it's nuts we got
this we got this twitter thread from
drew holden oh my god
he says they're lying to you media
outlets and personalities plus other
left wingers maliciously took a press
secretary quote out of context
to fraudulently make it sound like she
didn't care about the science she went
uh
science she went on to explain supports
the move to reopen schools
so here's what kaylee tweeted case study
in media bias
i said the science is very clear on this
the science is on our side here
we encourage our localities and states
to simply follow the science
open our schools but leave to the media
to deceptively suggest i was making the
opposite point
and now from drew holden we get a wave
of like every single outlet lying
every single one of them this is nuts
man so when i first saw this thing from
acosta i was like did she
really say this right check it out he
says i'm
as shocked as you surely are that acosta
of cnn is leading the charge to pretend
someone from the trump administration
made a point they obviously didn't
jim acosta tweeted the white house press
secretary on trump's push to reopen
schools
the science should not stand in the way
of this
jim acosta had many more characters he
could have used he could have clarified
what she really meant
you could have listened to kaylee
mckinney's full speech and
understood the context of what she was
saying i'm not going to bury this one
no suspense what she should have said is
the science will prove we were correct
the full context of what she was saying
is that
when the science is released you will
see
it supports us that's what she meant
listen to the full speech
the signs should not stand in the way of
this an unfortunate way of phrasing it
but you said it right there right listen
to the full
speech everybody needs to do it everyone
needs to be doing this
listening i i watch everything she puts
out everything she puts out i'm i'm now
listening to it all this is why people
don't trust the media i know you're
right
this is why when they shouldn't when
trump was doing his daily coronavirus
press briefings
his approval rating reached the highest
point of his presidency
in aggregate like not a single poll for
every single poll it was the highest
it had ever been and so immediately the
media is like shut him down stop letting
him speak
and then all the networks shut down
because oh what's that
well you can criticize him for the way
he speaks and his strategies and all
that stuff
when you learn the truth about what he's
saying you're like no it's not actually
that bad
yep so this is what they do i'm going to
stress this point for you
she clearly said the science is on our
side when she opened
she was saying i was talking to the
president and he and he said i want i
want schools fully reopened the science
should not stand in the way
on this the science the science should
not stand in the way of this
we're going to do blah blah blah the
science is on our side saying that
in the future the science won't be
stopping them
because it's on their side right so
simple
but they got they caught her they were
like oh we got a direct quote
the true the yeah the choice of words
was poor yup
yup check this out here's uh who is this
person
weijia zhang cbs news tweeted
the president has said unmistakable that
he wants schools to open when he says
open he means open and full kids being
able to attend each and every day at
school the science should not stand in
the way of this
full uh from the white house podium
science should not stand in the way of
reopening schools
this is everything look at this jim
roberts stunning
stunning jaw-dropping brave the white
house price secretary saying
uh just called for school's rope and
saying the science should not stand in
the way
uh in the way of this this is why i
never believe anything anymore from the
media and i always have to dig in
and there have been a few times where
i've actually gotten caught up and i'm
like oh
i should have fallen for that one i
should have known better yeah now i'm
over it
now they could be like they could be
like donald trump today announced that
he was going to launch a nuclear missile
into the sun i'd be like yeah no you
didn't i don't
i don't believe you right they'd be like
donald trump announced that he wouldn't
bought a big mac i'd like no he didn't
you're lying
donald trump came out and said hello no
he didn't that's not true he called you
fake news
i don't believe it i don't they they
could say donald trump smiled and waved
not buying it he was probably scratching
his nose for real
everything's out of context this is
insane look at this the washington post
white house press secretary caleb
mckennay the science should not stand in
the way
how absolutely insane has media become
little do they know
the science actually proves that schools
should be reopened
look at look at this one look at this
one this dude from nbc quote the science
should not stand in the way of this
press secretary says then he tweets
kennedy later added the science in her
words is on their side it's perfectly
safe to open
oh that's a nice little guardian bill
nye try to sneak it in there look at
this bill nye he goes he goes
way into it white house says science
should not stand in the way of opening
schools
i guess it's good to have it spelled out
the administration is generally not in
favor of science what
might surprise a few of us my oh my
science out of the way
bill nye come on bill no he he's you
know
you know he's not a scientist he's not a
scientist no he's not he gets dragged
all the engineer
exactly he doesn't have any he doesn't
even actually have any like hard science
degrees i guess
he was a comedian there's just there's
no there's not even a point in just
going through all this look at this pope
hat
war dnc war room ted lou he's a
politician all of these
lies man look wow this is a huge thread
that's true for you pride the lincoln
project that's funny
isn't he a russian and of course jay
rubin another star for the lincoln
project oh man
the krasensteins mrs krasenstein
look at that this is any chance they get
look how huge this threat is
orange man bed we got him everybody but
hold on hold on
look at all of these mainstream news
outlets saying
all of this stuff right now now try and
have a conversation
with one of your one of your friends who
doesn't is isn't in politics doesn't
watch a show like this
smash the like button and share this
video by the way you know what i'm doing
mentally while you're while you're
saying all that smashing the like button
oh no
i'm mentally prepping for those people
that you just mentioned
yep because i know they're gonna bring
this up oh yeah
adam well check this out and they're
gonna go and here's what they're gonna
do
they're gonna go cbs the washington post
the new york times
the wall street journal ted lou adam
schiff prove me wrong i have 12 sources
all proving this and then i'll and then
i'll actually
this is what i'll do i'll drop the
entire speech of what she
said and i'll be like show me where it
you know in she where she's saying the
science doesn't prove them correct
because that's not what she's saying the
science is very do you know what they're
going to say
i don't have the time
they're going to say they're gonna say i
just showed you 12
sources you sending me a youtube video
proves nothing
that's exactly what i have been told
when they give me that kind of stuff and
i go
all of these things that you're giving
me is allegedly this happened
allegedly this happened and i'm like
that that's not showing me that
something happened
i i i know i listened to her speech that
is not what she said that is not what
she meant
she's saying the science is in her side
so it shouldn't stand in the way of
reopening schools period
exactly exactly the full when you listen
to the full statement
you're like oh but see what the
journalists do because
this i really do believe that one of the
big things that divides the left and the
right today
is the ability to understand nuance
context
sarcasm irony it really does this is why
the npc meme is so apt
you're right because if she said you
know they listened to what
you know what i'm giving you the best
example when donald trump said hillary
clinton acid washed her server right
all that exactly all the npc people went
she put acid on her server but that
would
break it let me check snopes so then
nbc issued this nbc said [ __ ] check
hillary clinton
did not use a corrosive chemical on her
computers oh man yes it was
it was not speaking literally yes of
course but think about jokes
how they're like you can't say that it's
a joke i didn't mean it
i think ricky gervais uh says has a bit
like this where he's talking about
how he was uh joking about how he hated
pretzels on airplanes and he wants
peanuts but yeah you can't have peanuts
because one person might get sick
he's like i don't literally want
everyone to die from an
inhaling peanut dust or something like
that it's like i know it's a joke
he was making a joke it was meant to be
exaggerated
of course we know ricky gervais wants
people to die from peanut allergies
right that's why it's
silly it's it's meant to be humorous by
being extreme they can't understand
these things
so kayla mckennedy says something they
take it 100 literally
and now you have all these sources
proving she said it
yep and now i can just see it man
they're all going to be running around
like gobbling turkeys
echo chamber yeah the echo chamber is
running rampant right now
that's what we just saw that was a
thread of the echo chamber this is my
job this is what i do i wake up
i see the news and it says donald trump
today announced that he was going to be
executing
you know uh dogs and puppies and then
i'll be like whoa that's crazy
i better watch that video of him giving
the speech and then what they'll do is
it'll be like this
it'll be donald trump quote it's time to
start executing puppies and babe
and baby kittens and then i'll be like
whoa and everyone's like this is insane
i can't believe this
and then you watch it and it'll it'll be
trump going can you believe this these
crazy people who would say something
like it's time to start executing
puppies and baby kittens
what a horrible thing to say yeah
exactly they attribute the words to him
yeah they do things like that i know i
see it like even this right here
she's actually it appears she's quoting
trump
right she was like i talked to the
president he said this this and this the
science should not
the science should not stand in the way
of this blah blah blah blah you know we
want schools reopen
the science has already proven that
we're correct and then i think she makes
a specific reference too
but then they don't care i'm wondering
they attribute it to her
they don't care yeah i wonder how much
of it was tone
i wonder if if maybe he was saying
something like this the science
shouldn't stand in the way i mean it
should come up with the numbers that
we're expecting that's exactly she's
just relaying it kind of flatly
i mean because she's you know but not
even but not even that when you when
you you have to wait for someone to
finish and then if you're confused yes
question
yeah that's what journalists are
supposed to miss kennedy you said the
science should not stand in the way
you're not suggesting that you would
ignore
science that's not in favor could you
clarify that statement no no no tim come
on
they don't care about that they don't do
real they got her they got her
period got her that's it that's all that
mattered they got her boom
thank you this pr you can leave now
press secretary we got what we came for
you know you know you know what happened
once you walked off the podium what
there's like silence of all the
journalists sitting there for about five
seconds and then they slowly look at
each other
and they'll jump up they're like
high-fiving fighting each other popping
a beer and they're like we got her
yes finally we gotta win guys
she's been kicking our butts for well so
long it looks like
so true they've been working it looks
like we got them
whoa that's a lot of jobs all right go
ahead so so first first
i don't know what this source is
normally i use everything that's
certified by newsguard whoa
you're not using a certified source tim
i'm not
i'm clutching my pearls but there's one
reason there's one reason
uh this was actually shared by a blue
check journalist saying
we've got serious problems that's your
source yeah yeah but i didn't pull them
up so that's
i probably should have okay but they
also uh you know
it's basic whatever we know that vox and
the guardian have laid people off we
know that news has
generally been taking a hit this is this
is like i don't know the sources world
news daily
or something worldwide but they say uh
newsroom laughs at record high
challenger gray and christmas found that
there have been 11 000
27 job cuts announced this year compared
to 4087 in the first half of 2019.
the first half of 2019 was considered to
be like
the apocalypse really like 2019 itself
was just like
oh they were calling it a bloodbath
little do they know
it's getting worse what 2020 would bring
yeah
so vox is lying people off you know why
that's funny
because they're this is the outlet where
matthew iglesias the co-founder
was just canceled oh yeah that's right
and now he's tweeting very cryptic
help help i'm i'm trapped you know send
help tweets
he's tweeting things like i'd like to
talk about this but i can't
and you're like that's weird and he
randomly tweeted i have an opinion to
share but i won't
it's like okay thanks i better follow
him for all that
yeah breaking news he's basically got
duct tape on his mouth
that's like well dude the duck you you
made the tape yeah it's your company
meanwhile the other founder is like
ragging on him yeah he's the co-founder
right yeah matthew's a co-founder ezra
klein like threw some
some some shade some subtweet shade at
him like
you know when people talk about free
speech they're actually talking about
their power
and then he's like i would comment on
this but i've made a commitment so i
won't
it's like so so the context is basically
that matthew glacier signed this
harper's letter condemning cancel
culture
and so then his other co-founders are
like basically ragging on him and he
can't say anything because he's him
he has been canceled for signing the
letter you know what man
i have i have no sympathy for people who
want to dance in the highway and get hit
by a car
i mean i have a little bit to be honest
you know like because i don't i don't
it's like
you don't want anyone getting hurt i
don't want math matthew iglesias
co-founder of vox to be silenced i don't
want anyone to be silenced yeah i don't
want anyone
however however what am i supposed to do
it's like you're dancing in the highway
you get to buy a car
what am i what are we going to do are we
going to create a society where we put
like rubber padding everywhere
cars can only go 10 miles an hour
everybody's got to wear
you know what everyone goes in a bubble
you know you ever see those bubbles
people have yeah where they run around
in them and then bounce into each other
hamster balls is that well
it's like i mean base human their
hamster balls yeah they're big
inflatable bubbles and your feet are out
of them
oh no i don't know i know what you're
talking about yeah and then everyone
runs and jumps into each other yeah like
that's that's that's that's our
expectation for society
then we can finally feel safe right no i
couldn't i wouldn't be able to feel the
the feeling of the skateboard cracking
into my shin though
yeah i need no i need that pain
skateboards will be made of some kind of
uh uh
soft foam i don't know with it with a
very thin plastic
you will not be allowed to uh you have
to strap your feet in on both
of the trucks oh great so no tricks and
you you can't push someone can push you
one time
that's it we're all going to wear gray
jumpsuits everyone's heads will be
shaven
equilibrium totally everyone must wear
the same thing
in order to eliminate all biases and all
prejudice and make
everyone finally the same and to be
truly safe peaceful
peaceful everybody's got a you know i i
used to think it would be a great
jumpsuit
now i don't think that would work
because you can still see someone's
figure
like oh good point you're too tall whoa
whoa
you're you're too thin you're right
you're too wide well no no no you're too
short too thin won't be an issue because
i won't be starving
you know there's not gonna be any food
in the new communist utopia so what
everyone's going to be thin
everyone's going to be starving i hope
not well that's communism i hope it
doesn't happen
but that's that that's communism you're
right so so when we have the communist
utopia they won't have to worry about
people being too tall because they'll
all be starving so they'll stop growing
at a certain point
so everyone can just wear it's going to
be like it's going to rest on your head
and it's going to be a big white
cylinder so that no
like a lampshade right exactly but
covering all the way to the floor
and it'll just be cylinders moving
around but you can't talk you have to
type
and then the robot talks for you hello
good day welcome to the tim cast irl
i would use my real voice but then you
would know i
am male you must smash the like button
now smash gently think about what
they're what they're trying to implement
with all this like critical race theory
and gender theory and all the stuff
yeah how do you stop any of it i
i don't know talk keep talking about it
logically racism that's what i'm doing
as much as i can no no no no i mean i
mean how do they win
oh how how do they stop white supremacy
i don't know it feels like they're
trying to convince everybody that
everyone's white supremacists well so
the way i look at it is
the only way you can actually have their
version of equality with no privilege
would be like i described it yep
everybody is
you know starving and small they wear
giant lamp shed things on their heads
that go all the way down so you can't
see it's like it floats like a two feet
from your body and
you just you move around and shuffling
and or like cousin it wigs
right exactly yeah you don't know what
it is it's just hair
and everyone's required to talk with a
very high pitcher or like like
ya sh you know you never see her oh yeah
but that's that's the only way to solve
it right i guess so i was thinking this
before when i used to work for
uh when i went to o'hare airport because
of all the security restrictions that
made no sense
i was like maybe the future will be if
you want to fly you got to wear a
jumpsuit you can't bring anything with
you
because they're slowly just banning like
nail clippers are banned then shampoos
ban
you know and the stupidest thing was the
security product like protocols made
zero sense
because if you worked for the company
you would just drive in you would drive
up
you'd pull up to a checkpoint they'd
wave you'd show them your id they'd wave
you in they wouldn't search you
you could bring whatever you wanted and
then you were in the airport
with whatever you wanted jeez yeah not
only that well this was a while ago
right
it's still it's the same way oh really
so well i don't know about the employee
parking lot but i can tell you
that they would always tell us if you're
coming to work
you can use your key card to enter
what's called the bag room it's like
when you when you go to the baggage
carousels
yeah there's a door and you can just
swipe the door opens and now you are in
the secured area
okay so they would be like well you're
not supposed to go in that way
we want you to go through security
because even if you're employed you go
through security
but
you have to have the door there so that
the employees can fix
problems so people would show up walk
right up and not go to security and just
swipe and walk on in
yeah or people like literally everybody
who drove in
you pull up to a checkpoint they'd be
like how's it going hi you swipe your
card have a nice day morning jerry
and you bring your car in and i was just
like how stupid is it
that they're gonna ban all these things
i could literally fill my trunk up with
nail clippers
and they wouldn't they'd open and be
like you got a lot of nail clippers
there tim and i'd be like that's right
but have a nice day buddy i like my
nails
cut perfectly no i'd be on the house
every hour
i'm telling you my new business a
subscription nail clipper service
i'm telling you i'm going to be rich
they'd be like yeah great go for it
bye-bye
underground airport nail clippers
now i open my trench coat i'm like you
you need some nail clippers i got the
nail clippers
i see those nails are a little long they
make you throw those clippers away
okay right here they got you they
wouldn't care you need toenail clippers
oh i got i got fingernail clippers
toenail clippers
cuticle cutters yeah you got a cat i got
a cat nail clipper too
now the point is though i used to think
about that and then
now that we're in this era of social
justice everything's offensive
everyone's privileged
right how do you remove privilege
that you know what colorism is sounds
familiar but it
it's a social justice term meaning that
lighter-skinned people have more
privilege than darker-skinned people i
guess
is that what is that how you do that
yeah i would say so and i actually have
something to say about this because
i know someone's going to mention maybe
in super chat's a book called harrison
bergeron
which is uh like a dystopian story where
everyone is
equal and that means people with a sense
of pitch have like these things
installed in their ears where you can't
hear anything
and you can't sing and you're all the
same height you have like your shins
broken so you can do all this stuff and
it's it's it's horrible dystopia it's
awful
have you read it i haven't read it i
think i listened to it but
i like to imagine what the world would
be like that's the same and they're in
their happy utopia
audiobook that's basically you read the
book yeah i mean you listened to the
auto booth yeah i did yeah thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you